this is Dominic Dominic they know all
that all right I'm sorry I don't usually
do this but something just came to me
last week
nothin at all Solid Snake's to tell me
about you know the bloke ooh spirits
were killed by as a psychology onna did
all these horrible things to his parents
bodies and that's why he has to carry
the Box around all the time he's a
fucking balloon he doesn't have any
parents
yeah I can look up Wikipedia guy your
story makes no sense so the other week
I'm sitting down tending bar what lo and
behold who wants pie
Solid Snake so I literally jump over the
counter and I run up to him he was
walking out into the parking lot and I
said what what's this bullshit about you
having dead parents Lou you are freaky
Cologne I know the story
I don't know about that and I said you
don't understand meet the Fox with the
strong connection I said I know exactly
what this is you like your box you can
explain why some sunshine disconnection
a you make ups of bullcrap stored
that all of a sudden the box started
talking and he said Hey lay off my guy
me and him we have a special bond
and I think that that fucking box just
talk to me
and snicker look down the box and Lisa
will have to do anything to a box we
don't have to do a thing and I'll so
what if talking about doing thing is
just a box he's not gonna do anything
all this in the box without God
I throw my hands up like nobody's
business and the box continues to talk
to me he says
Solid Snake is taking me places and you
ain't gonna get in the way of it the box
is a lie the boat's holding that gun at
me and it's a one then just on the
corner of my eyes that's all a woman
calling 9-1-1 I don't know how she told
him that a box was holding a gun but
some housing on the idea cross the boss
looks at snaky Lisa's Nuka and sure
enough he got out of grenade and he blew
her to keep him calm and solace Nick
looks down at the box and says okay we
killed the woman we don't have to kill
the bartender and the box says yes we do
point the gun at my face and he said say
goodnight pretty
conserve myself pretty brother oh my god
I'm gonna die suddenly the police came
in and they shot the gun out of the
boxes
side of the box Moffat dense double the
Boston literally done to the policeman's
head and started eating his face the
books his teeth his fucking books his
teeth one policeman came in they start
punching the box and offense but I'm
watching her he was sort of punching the
cop in the face as well you see though
then it scored finally the cop managed
to get the bucks off and they shot a
couple of rounds in it then and lay down
bleeding boxes complete okay again you
get my point
and solid snake leads down and it looks
at the box the box looks right affidavit
says I thought we had something speak I
thought we had something
to
roll down Solid Snake's pays identity
that's a tough tough kid there and he's
crying over books you see I guess the
box was trying to ride Solid Snake's
shirttails in the fame and fortune
don't really know how many famous boxes
there are coming to mind but the one
that can hold a gun and eat people's
faces surely that's gone get some of
these attention but I guess that wasn't
enough the books died right there the
middle of the parking lot for everybody
to see
few days late either they buried the
holes
placed in a butt big up on top listening
I really want to shed a tear what Solid
Snake
I have no idea whatever that box went
through I guess it must've been
something really traumatic something
about the close to Kenna
it's one of those mysteries we'll just
never know
Spurs OHS ask him what his boss pointed
a gun at me trying to kill me keep our
distance
some things are just better left
unresolved
for me at least you see a lot of strange
things as a bartender
see lost rapes things at the pixel baths
so I'll see a lot of strange things as a
bartender a pizza palace
a lot that really ain't no toy